with russian forces moving three miles
closer in the past 24 hours according to
a senior u.s defense official here are
the latest developments
there's been renewed fighting on the
outskirts of the capital kiev and in the
eastern city of hakib a psychiatric
hospital was hit by a russian airstrike
there's no word on casualties but 330
people were at the hospital
denis pro lutz ivan francis and live
denipro is the next likely target as
russia's southern offensive moves north
two other strikes near airports in the
western city of lutsk and ivano francis
were also reported sky's special
correspondent alex crawford reports from
bravery an eastern suburb of the capital
cave
russian tanks and other armoured
vehicles in an eastern suburb of kiev
now abandoned and damaged but gleefully
driven by the ukrainians who ambushed
them and pushed the troops into retreat
but this is demonstrable evidence the
russian military is on the move and
trying several different routes to get
into the capital the ukrainians are
grasping this as an opportunity to
emphasize just how capable they are of
defending their main city
the drone footage released by ukraine's
armed forces is now being lauded as a
tremendous military defense
in the footage the russians come under
repeated attack with soldiers running
for cover rockets frantically fired in
this built up area it's the main eastern
highway leading directly into the centre
of the capital
the battle has left military debris
scattered all over the e-95 road which
may also help in hindering russian
progress you can still see smoke in the
distance where the russian tanks managed
to get to they're trying to hold them
back but they're very worried that
they're going to try and make a push
from here
or again try down this main road into
bravery
but the activity around the capitals
outskirts has definitely picked up over
the past 24 hours
these pictures filmed by journalists
with ukrainian soldiers appear to show
the troops under fire as they engage
their russian counterparts apparently in
a village in the greater kiev area
we were invited to see some of the
casualties in bravery a number of them
children
including a 14 year old girl shot whilst
fleeing in a car with her family
the bullets hit her hand and shoulder
she's only a teenager and was with her
four-year-old brother grandmother and
parents
we were driving down the main road from
my grandmother's she says and they just
started shooting at us her father sir
guy had part of his hand blown away
he and his family are lucky to survive
he told us the russian troops seemed
very panicky
to me they were scared he said and they
shot everything that moved
there's increased tension around the
capital and soldiers are wary of
everyone they suspect russian saboteurs
might be posing as journalists
he is his russian
journalist and they're on the hunt for
one in particular
the hospital staff are edgy too and have
found themselves treating some soldiers
but overwhelmingly their patients are
civilian casualties
physician
it's very hard physically and
emotionally he says to see young people
being crippled and dying for no reason
satellite pictures appear to show the
huge russian military convoy
repositioning apparently regrouping to
encircle the capital before launching a
prolonged attack on the city centre
probably within days
but the man with hero status in ukraine
for raising millions to support their
armed forces insists they're ready we
will fight from every window
we will fight from every basement
now we have enough anti-tank missiles uh
thanks for our allies from the united
kingdom from the united states
so
they will um
they will lose tanks every street every
block
every crossroads
there are more and more barricades going
up in and around the capital
they're digging trenches and this is in
the middle of the city although we're
not showing the location for security
reasons
either way soldiers and civilians are
preparing for either attack or siege
they have created a whole network of
these trenches as much as protection but
also from where they can
mount fighting positions
[Applause]
they've been taking on russian troops
around several points on the edges of
the capital but there's a growing
expectation that the city is headed into
a very grim few days or weeks
alex crawford sky news here